[موسيقى]
دائما تحاول انك تتعلم ما تبقى عن مكانك
يعني تفتكر انك فاهم كل شيء انه دائما
العالم بتتغير وتطور متلازم يعني
تتقدم مع التطورات اللي بتصير فتنمي
المهارات اللي تحتاجها اليوم ممكن من
المهارات حق امس
ايه اكتب مع نفسي
افكر افكار جديده
مراجعات جديده
ممكن نجرب كل يعني كل مره نجرب شيء جديد
نحاول نغير من طريقه الشغل اللي نسويها
انا اهم شيء عندي يكون عندي انا طموح لنا
حتى لو قابلني صعوبات في الحياه ان انا
اتحدى نفسي واتغلب على نفسي في كل مشكله
بتقابلني في الحياه ويكون دائما حاطط
مستوى اللي في المعين في دماغي ان انا
لازم اوصل له هدف ان انا هاوصل له ايا كان
الصعوبات اللي بتقابلني ودائما ان انا ما
يقسم مع كل خبطه بتقابلني لا بالعكس ان
انا اتحدى كل المواجهات اللي بتقابلني
عشان احقق الحلم اللي انا اوصل له في اي
نتيجه
[موسيقى]